Speaker 1: There's a really interesting new report
from CNN's Gabby Ore and Steve Cohen torno about
Donald Trump's growing fury, quite frankly, that
Florida Republican Gov. Ron DeSantis, known to
some in the pandemic era, as Ron death sentence.
You may remember that Trump's furious that
DeSantis is increasingly popular and increasingly
being talked about as an alternative to Donald
Trump for 2022. Now, you might recall that back in
July at CPAC, they did a straw poll. They do these
at all CPAC. And Donald Trump easily won that 2024
straw poll. He Trump had 70 percent of the vote.
The other, the only other notable participant was
Ron DeSantis, with 21 percent of that straw poll
vote. And throughout the pandemic, when Trump
was president and Ron DeSantis ignored, every
COVID guideline opened the state, I think it was
to WWE wrestling and UFC fights very early. Later,
DeSantis said, cruise ships, if you want to
leave from Florida, you can't require vaccines.
Trump loved it. Trump was all about Ron
DeSantis and Trump. Guests were all about Ron
DeSantis. He's great. He's the best. How terrific
pro-business. He's been doing great things. OK,
but now, as Ron DeSantis has become more popular
and is being seen increasingly almost like a more
competent version of Donald Trump, all of Trump's
terrible ideas but more competence to actually
get them done. Trump is apparently furious,
and DeSantis also seems to be realizing, Hey,
I might be up against Trump in 2024. I need to
start distancing as well. Let's take a look at
the CNN report about this, and it is very, very
interesting, which says people close to both men
first noticed the palpable shift in Trump's
posture towards DeSantis earlier this year as
enthusiasm for the Florida governor swelled
among donors and Republican operatives who
praised his laissez faire response to the COVID
pandemic. The more DeSantis his popularity soared,
the more obsessed Trump became with receiving
credit for his political celebrity. In April,
Trump told Fox News DeSantis would certainly be
under consideration for VP if he were to launch
a campaign in 2024. By 2008. By October, Trump was
demanding he publicly rule out a White House bid
of his own. So as recently as last month, Trump
was saying DeSantis needs to come out and say,
I won't run. And of course, the Santas
hasn't done that because DeSantis might well
be thinking of running. It's not that Trump
is complaining about Ron, but he likes Ron,
too. He likes to remind Ron and others that
he made him set a person close to Trump,
who added, Trump has been telling people around
him that the Santas could show more gratitude.
A statement to CNN from Trump spokesman Taylor
Budo, which appeared to confirm Trump's obsession
with receiving credit for DeSantis a success.
Voodoo, which said the former president's 2020
victory in Florida paved the way for Republicans,
including Ron DeSantis, to sweep in 2022
and suggested Trump catapulted DeSantis into
the governor's mansion with his endorsement.
Though the two remain in regular contact, Trump
is increasingly irritated at the Sanders's refusal
to publicly dismiss the 2024 bid of his own. If
the former president decides to run to people
close to the situation, said DeSantis has
privately assured Trump he has no intention
of challenging him. But they noted Trump won't
be fully satisfied until he says so publicly,
though DeSantis previously dismissed 2024 chatter
as nonsense. He has avoided taking the unequivocal
public vow vowed not to challenge Trump. He
has filed to run for reelection in 2022. The
best case scenario for the left is that Trump
goes full metal jacket against Ron DeSantis.
DeSantis then retaliates and it becomes a
huge nightmare, and it helps Republicans
and implode. Now I am the first to admit the
country is in serious trouble when a governor
with the deaths of thousands tens of thousands
of innocent Americans from COVID on his hands
is seeing his popularity take off. That bodes
really poorly for the United States of America.
But you just saw 70 million people. Vote for a
doofus imbecile who killed hundreds of thousands
with his sheer incompetence in mishandling the
pandemic. So we've been in serious trouble for
a while now. They seem to want, to some
degree, something like DeSantis. There's a
very different direction that the Republican
electorate could be going, which is to say
we need a different type of Republican. We
need like Mitt Romney. We need Liz Cheney,
who, by the way, Liz Cheney voted more than 90
percent of the time with Trump's position. So it's
not like Liz Cheney is some big victory, right?
But it would be different for Republicans to say
the Trump thing didn't work, and we're not
going to keep going with it. They seem to want
a crazy Trump like figure that would be more able
to do the things that Donald Trump wanted to do,
but wasn't able to do. And unfortunately, that
very well could be Ron DeSantis very, very scary
stuff because the left is so poorly positioned
going into twenty two, like we talked about at
the top of the show, were kind of relegated to
this very lame position of having to hope that
they fight against themselves and DeSantis
versus Trump could be a really great thing.